#bpw science hashtags 1 dem der
kampfbegriff hält muss zu alt ist lohan
be hard day's normalerweise interessiert
sich kaum jemand für die wissenschaft
aber in pharmakonzerne überteuerte
produkte rechtfertigen möchten den
scharlatanen medizin verticken möchten
oder wenn politiker nichts vom
klimawandel hören möchten dann brauchen
sie eigentlich noch eine gute pr
wissenschaftliche studien für eine gute
wer aber nein nicht für alle
behauptungen gibt es wissenschaftliche
belege und jetzt seien sie auch in
studien mangelt originals können helfen
pretoria dieser prätorius stecken
betrüger die sich als wissenschaftliche
zeitschriften ausgeben aber in
wirklichkeit einfach jeden scheiß
publizieren und ich meine auch wirklich
jeden scheiß einfach nur gegen ein
bisschen geld er kaufte wissenschaft und
das kommt dabei raus aspirin plus c ist
eigentlich nur aspirin und vitamin c
aber wir verkaufen es einfach mal
doppelt so teuer und jetzt haben wir
auch noch eine studie die er sagt dass
es sich lohnt in sagt krebs medikament
namens gc macht hat zwar in der realität
keine wirkung aber wir haben studien die
es zeigen warum sind die menschen so
dumm und glauben diesen ausgebildeten
klimaforschern wenn wir doch diejenigen
sind mit den studien die sich menschen
eigenhändig erkauft haben doch die
düsternis hören da noch nicht auf neben
scharlatanen veröffentlichen auch
ernsthafte wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler in diesen predators
girls aber doch nicht in deutschland in
deutschland rund 5000 darunter max
planck frauenhofer helmholtz und leibniz
institute und auch top universitäten wie
die rwth aachen diese skandale wurden
aufgedeckt unter dem hashtag 61 nach
monatelanger recherche von ndr wdr und
der süddeutschen zeitung und bevor ihr
jetzt schon
denkt dann hörte ich mal das 1 dieses
game girls sind nichts neues und sie
sind in der wissenschaftlichen community
auch schon seit jahren bekannt
aber warum habt ihr davon noch nie was
gehört bestimmt hat es die wissenschaft
verschwiegen
dieser weg sei predator originals wurden
in der wissenschaftlichen community
nicht nur offen diskutiert sondern sogar
erforscht bis es kein schwein
interessiert
es ist ein ziemlich akademisches thema
das aber für jeden von uns unglaublich
relevant ist und dass die aktuellen
berichterstattungen das thema endlich
mal in die breite öffentlichkeit tragen
feiere ich aber ich bin ein bisschen
sauer über die art und weise der
berichterstattung und auch über diesen
heftig vom darauf am ende noch das
modell steckt x1 gibt es einige artikel
auch podcasts videos fernsehreportagen
verlinkt ich euch alles unten aber
einige punkte kam meiner meinung nach zu
kurz und die möchte ich in diesem video
nachholen weil ich sie unglaublich
wichtig finde also freude der sonne
macht es euch bequem setzt euch dieses
video wird mein app von trennung freunde
freunde wenn der trainer so spät kommt
dann wisst ihr ich meine es ernst
irgendwann mit einer kurzen einordnung
was ist eigentlich das ausmaß dieses
problems 5000 wissenschaftler innen in
deutschland das sind rund 1,3 prozent
wenn man jetzt noch mit einberechnet wie
viele pieper jährlich publiziert werden
dann ist der anteil wenn man sich die
einzelnen publikationen anschaut
wahrscheinlich im promillebereich das
jetzt erst mal schön zu hören das
problem ist also nicht völlig oder
control aber wissenschaft muss an den
allerhöchsten standards gemessen werden
und dass so was überhaupt passiert egal
wie klein der anteil ist ist eine
schande und inakzeptabel
dem ernst wie kann so etwas überhaupt
passieren
seid ihr bereit für die abgründe der
wissenschaft vor der sonne seit so gut
und versetzt durch mal kurz in eine
chemikerin was bist du eine chemikerin
in ihrer doktorarbeit und was ist das
wichtigste für seine doktorarbeit dass
sich unbekannte fragen aufschlüsseln
kann und die welt ein bisschen besser
fischen
dafür sei es noch mal dass sich
innovative technologien entwickeln ein
versuch nochmal das heißt die
doktorarbeit wichtiger teil meiner
ausbildung ist wo ich lerne das
wichtigste ist dass du publiziert denn
solange du nichts veröffentlicht bist du
als wissenschaftlerin nichts wert
publish or perish veröffentliche oder
verdecke zähler
also was ist das wichtigste in einer
doktorarbeit publizieren
dieser publikations druck ist eine ganz
schöne scheiße und wir stehen nicht bloß
nicht reiche geht es nicht um ruhig muss
so viele pieper schreiben und ich muss
was leisten ich komme mit dem druck
nicht klar mimimi mit nein
also der druck ist durchaus sehr
belastend für die wissenschaftlerin aber
scheiß auf die wissenschaftler also
jetzt nur für diese argumentation der
publikations druck ist schlecht für die
wissenschaft wissenschaft nein schlecht
für die wissenschaft der publikations
druck ist schlecht für die wissenschaft
warum es so schlecht weil nur positive
ergebnisse publiziert werden dabei ist
forschung nun mal keine
aneinanderreihung positiver experimente
forschung kann auch heißen dass du
wochen monate oder jahre an etwas
forscht mit fleiß herzblut und hirn und
trotzdem nichts brauchbares dabei
rumkommt webpages wissenschaftliche
durchbrüche sind nicht
abhängig von guten ideen fleiß und zeit
sondern natürlich ist auch zufall glück
und pech mit dabei außerdem ist jede
erkenntnis wichtig auch eine negative
zum beispiel h das hat jetzt schon mal
nicht geklappt oder seltsam dieses
experiment widerspricht allen meinen
anderen das stimmt muss ich eine ganz
neue hypothese entwickeln meinen ganzen
forschungsplanung stellen und schwupps
ist die doktorarbeit auch schon vorbei
an manchen unis bekommst du deinen
doktortitel erst verlieren denn du zum
beispiel drei paper publiziert hast
obwohl eigentlich jeder weiß dass man
positive ergebnisse nicht erzwingen kann
wird genau das von den studierenden und
promovierenden verlangt er hat
vielleicht schon worauf das ganze
hinausläuft aber bevor wir weitermachen
müssen wir noch kurz klären wieso ein
publikations prozess idealerweise
aussieht zurück zu dir der chemikerin
oder dem chemiker du weißt jetzt also
ich muß publizieren das heißt du hast du
sammelst daten du wertet sie aus und
heurige sie ergeben sehen du schreibst
deine ergebnisse in einem manuskript
zusammen und schickt dieses manuskript
an ein wissenschaftliches genie erste
hürde für sein manuskript die
redakteurin des journals ist sich
unbedingt spezialistin seines
fachgebiets aber 70 schon mal oft ein
manuskript hand und fuß hat und ob es zu
dem girl passt denn manuskript besteht
diese erste prüfung und die redakteurin
schickt es weiter an zwei bis drei
reviewer die sind jetzt spezialisten
deines fachgebiet die review prüfen
jetzt ob dein manuskript relevant genug
ist innovativ genug ob es mehrwert hat
ob alles wissenschaftlich korrekt ist
wie es nie erfahren wer diese menschen
sind damit du sie nicht bequatschen
kannst du erhältst darauf eine liste mit
kommentaren dieser review
die haben vielleicht noch mal nachfragen
weil ich irgendwas unklar vielleicht
hast du mal einen fehler gemacht
vielleicht vielen daten vielleicht
musste auch noch mal zurück ins labor
und experiment nachholen was auch immer
es ist du tust das so korrigiert dass
geschickt zurück der ganze prozess kann
sie auch noch mal wiederholen
jedenfalls wenn ganze
wenn alles stimmt wird stein paper
publiziert das war jetzt der einfache
weg
es kann aber auch ganz anders laufen
review können dich auch reject also zum
beispiel denken du musst noch mindestens
ein halbes jahr länger im labor arbeiten
bevor die ausreichend daten hast oder
noch schlimmer dass sie überhaupt kein
grund sehen warum du das jemals
publizieren solltest oder du wirst
direkt im ersten schritt vom redakteur
getötet
es ist also nicht so einfach so eine
publikation durchzubekommen dieser
kontrollprozess durch kollegen durch
pearce wird peer review genannt wollen
wir uns jetzt erst mal darüber dass
qualitätssicherung bei
wissenschaftlichen studien groß
geschrieben wird
aber jetzt erinnern wir uns an wie
chopin spätestens jetzt sollten wir
feststellen
eine hohe qualität von publikationen und
ein hoher output an erzwungen hoher
output von publikationen werden nicht
immer vereinbar seien
ich wiederhole der publikations druck
schadet der wissenschaft wie sieht
dieser schaden genau aus im besten fall
kommt es zu sogenannten salami theorie
pro wissenschaftler innen die gute
arbeit machen sich gedanken machen
müssen ob sie das werk als solches
lassen oder ob sie es vielleicht nicht
doch in drei kleinere paper einteilen
ohne wissenschaftlichen grund einfach
nur dann mit ihrem publikationsliste
länger wird wenn ich statt einem paper
drei paper draus machen darf ich
promovieren in weniger guten fall kommt
es zu verschwendung von steuergeldern
und potenzial wenn die leute anfangen
nur noch nach loh henning huth zu
greifen
das heißt ohne inspiriert und innovativ
ihre forschung nach publiziert barkeit
auslegen und nicht den interessanten
großen fragen nachgehen weil die
komplizierter sind und länger dauern
im schlimmen fall führt es zu leuten die
ihre forschung besser darstellen als sie
wirklich ist
dieses experiment widerspricht all
meinen anderen es ist einfach nie
passiert und im schlimmsten fall gibt es
überall und ehrliche menschen die
täuschen und betrügen und durch den
publikations druck um so mehr incentive
bekommen
kurz gesagt die cms das diesem s stiegen
nun pretoria germans empore aber es ist
nicht ganz so einfach wie es scheint
denn auch hier geht es leider um welchen
thema publizieren muss sich als autorin
immer eine gewisse gebühr an den verlag
zahlen aber das meiste geld machen die
wissenschaftlichen verleger mit pay
walls wäre die studie lesen will muss
zahlen der dieses elite gibt sagte
erstens sind publikation ja eben dazu da
um sie mit den kolleginnen zu teilen
damit sich die wissenschaft aufbauend
darauf weiter entwickelt weiß ist die
neueste forschung mit öffentlichen
geldern also mit steuergeldern
finanziert und die steuerzahler haben
kein zugriff auf die ergebnisse einer
arbeit die sie selbst finanzieren und
genau so absurd viele wissenschaftler
haben nach der veröffentlichung keinen
freien zugriff mehr auf ihr eigenes pay
zum glück habe ich noch das manuskript
elite bietet akte 2011 gründete eine
doktorand aus kasachstan die unglaublich
erfolgreiche schatten bibliothek sei
ohne millionen wissenschaftlicher
studien die es normalerweise eben nur
hinter den payrolls gibt werden hier
geklaut und bereitgestellt es ist
natürlich illegal und trotzdem wird es
von 4 unterstützt weil man sich
natürlich fragen kann wieso ein verlag
überhaupt gewinn machen darf
mitarbeit von steuergeldern bezahlt
wurde
es gibt aber auch eine andere lösung
seit etwa zehn jahren gibt es sogenannte
open access journal
das geschäftsmodell von open access
nicht die leserzahlen sondern die
autoren ist natürlich auch problematisch
wenn ich als autorin geld dafür zahlen
muss dass ich eigentlich nur meine
arbeit machen aber wenigstens ist diese
arbeit dann für jeden frei zu
ich wohl open access prinzipiell eine
gute idee ist bietet es natürlich den
rahmen für die predators deren
geschäftsmodell ist denkbar einfach der
autor zahlt und das journal publiziert
es gibt kein peer review es gibt keine
qualitätskontrolle man erkauft sich eine
wissenschaftliche veröffentlichung es
gibt so viele geile beispiele wo
wissenschaftler demonstriert haben die
abartige mich diese genies sind sie zum
beispiel diese kreative antwort auf eine
spam mail mit einer manuskript
einreichung namens gimme hope you
fucking mailing list ja natürlich wurde
dieses ding so wie alles andere
automatisch akzeptiert was aber nicht
selten passiert ist das unerfahrene
studierende und promovierende auf diese
jonas rein fallen das wissenschaftliche
äquivalenz zu diesen typischen
spam-e-mails wo dir der nigerianische
prinz schreibt dass er dir 12 millionen
dollar verehren möchte man kriegt von
denen auch e mails nur darin steht dann
das sie gerne deine arbeit
veröffentlichen würden die wollen mein
manuskript das ist besser als geld jetzt
kommt das richtig sagen wir ich bin rein
gefallen habe daraus weil sie mein
manuskript eingereicht selbst wer nicht
mein fehler bemerkte und mein manuskript
zurückziehen möchte wird ist
wahrscheinlich trotzdem veröffentlicht
falls sogar ohne gebühr das ist
natürlich das beste was die sind
präparator es passieren kann dass echte
wissenschaftler ihre echte
wissenschaftler aus versehen einreichen
mit der sie sich dann wiederum brüsten
können brettert originals heißen zurecht
treasury weil sie buchstäblich
auffällige sind denen
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
oft zum opfer fahren wir wissen jetzt
nicht wie viele wissenschaftler opfer
sind und wie viele betrügen wollten aber
schauen wir uns doch mal die betrüger
etwas genauer an
denn hier müssen wir eine extrem
wichtige differenzierung treffen achtung
achtung
wichtige differenzierung lasst uns nicht
alle menschen die absichtlich bei einem
kredite return publizieren
in nur eine schublade stecken das
wenigstens zwei schubladen draus machen
du gerade nummer eins wissenschaftler
innen die ihre publikationsliste
erweitern möchten diese wissenschaftler
haben null interesse daran dass
irgendjemand diese paper liest und sie
haben auch gute chancen dass die niemand
liest weil diese schrott girls
letztendlich wie der mülleimer der
wissenschaft sind und sie werden beten
und hoffen dass niemand der sie
irgendwann mal einstellen möchte da mal
genauer hinschaut menschen die unehrlich
sind die betrügen und schummeln dürfen
keine wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler seien aber ihre schrott
paper werden keinen aktiven schaden
anrichten weil die niemand lesen wir das
einfach nur eine große
ressourcenverschwendung schublade hat
zwei große lobby ist ein politiker
aktivisten populisten scharlatane
ich habe jetzt nur eine schublade es
geht um alle nicht wissenschaftler in
dieser schublade besteht kein
publikations druck diese menschen wollen
ihre eigene agenda durchsetzen mit hilfe
falscher wissenschaft besten fall werden
hier produkte geschönt für bessere
verkaufszahlen im schlimmsten fall
kommen krebskranke menschen zu schaden
die glauben eine neue therapie gefunden
zu haben diese paper die schaden nicht
nur der wissenschaft sondern wirklich
direkt auch laien denn jetzt aber
scharlatane mit der hoffnung und der
gesundheit kranker menschen spielen dann
sind peter torry dörners nicht das
zentrale problem sie sind ein mittel von
vielen zum zweck zu einem abscheulichen
zweck der strafrechtlich verfolgt werden
sollte ok aber was machen wir jetzt
gegen diese pretoria girls fünf dinge
können wir tun und wer auch immer ihr
seid die ihr gerade dieses video schaut
mindestens einer dieser fünf lösungen
seid ihr persönlich gefragt erster
aufklärung der wissenschaftler innen
es gibt bereits schriftliche guidelines
davon muss es mehr geben und das muss
genauere spezifischere gehen am besten
für jede fachrichtung natürlich sind
alle wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler sowie so gefragt bei
allem was sie tun ihr handeln zu
reflektieren und sich selbst
weiterzubilden zweiter die unis die
forschungseinrichtungen und die verleger
müssen jeder für sich aber auch
gemeinsam schärfere policies aufsetzen
und durchsetzen aus dem kammern
gemeinsam whitelist und blacklists über
verschiedene verleger oder germans
aufstellen ansätze dazu gibt es auch
schon links in die beschreibung dritten
sec mit der publish or perish mentalität
müssen neu überlegen wie man leistung
qualität und mehrwert wissenschaftlicher
arbeit sind voller evaluieren kann aus
über eine publikationsliste vierter
wissenschaftsjournalismus von experten
ist es leicht ein schrott journal aus
ihrem fachgebiet anzuschauen und sofort
zu sehen das ist schrott für den laien
ist es quasi unmöglich und deswegen
brauchen wir guten
wissenschaftsjournalismus der auch einem
gewissen publish or perish widersteht
sehe auch schwierigkeiten in der
aktuellen berichterstattung über dieses
thema zum beispiel war ich ein bisschen
enttäuscht über die reportage die am
montag in der ard
da hätte ich mir einen sachlichen ton
gewünscht ich hätte mir mehr infos
gewünscht und generell weil ich glaube
ich einfach ein bisschen enttäuscht über
die monatelanger recherche war zumindest
für mich als wissenschaftlerin da nicht
viel neues rauskam und wenn man mit dem
rundfunkbeitrag auf eine scan konferenz
nach new york fliegt um dort einen
studenten zu konfrontieren
der mit forschungs steuergeldern auf
eine scan konferenz nach new york fliegt
dann ist das ironisch 5
öffentlicher druck hier bin ich sehr
dankbar für die aktuellen und neuen
berichterstattungen denn sie bringen
eine neue dimension in die diskussion
navarre konkrete beispiele die jedem
klar machen sollten dass das hier kein
akademisches problem ist sondern etwas
das uns alle betrifft
ich hoffe wirklich dass unter der
schärferen beobachtung durch die
öffentlichkeit und durch vielleicht ein
bisschen druck die punkte 1 bis 3 dich
gerade genannt habe endlich mal
ernsthaft angepackt werden ich habe
letzte woche immer im video über die
macht der zuschauer gesprochen jetzt ist
genauso moment deswegen ist es mir so
wichtig gewesen dass ihr wisst was los
ist damit ihr euch vielleicht auch in
die öffentliche diskussion einmischen
könnt wenn ihr möchtet aber ich finde
wir brauchen einen neuen heftig denn
fakes 1 in anlehnung an fähig news lädt
nicht zu einer konstruktiven diskussion
ein
ich habe sowas von die schnauze voll von
fake news das als scheinargument gegen
alles verwendet sieht was einem nicht
passt diese art von debatte hat bei
einem wissenschaftlichen thema nichts
verloren deshalb habe ich einen keks
frage an euch unter welchem hashtag
könnte man dieses ganze problem
konstruktiver diskutieren
reals 1 ihrem ein vorschlag mit ihr noch
vorschläge habt kriegt ihr von mir ein
keks im ok vorschläge habt dann schreibt
ihnen die kommentare und koppelt sie
bitte an den hashtag real estate will
damit ich sie auch leichter finde ich
habe heute ungelogen heute etwas in der
post bekommen und das machen wir mal in
der endart auf
wirklich fallen lassen alter freunde der
sonne
danke steht dass meine freundin für
sonne ich werde mich für zwei wochen
verabschieden denn wir machen eine
kleine sommerpause
ich sollte das was ich gerade über
publisher per ich gesagt habe jetzt
endlich auch auf diesem kanal ernst
nehmen qualität vor quantität ist werde
ich mir ein bisschen verschnaufpause
gönnen und ich komme dann in zwei wochen
wieder volle kanne am 16 august und bis
dahin bleibt
ich freue mich auf eure kommentare und
da